you always said I'm probably not gonna
get married I definitely don't want kids
with your devotion to comedy do you
think a wife would have gotten in the
way of that would that have shifted your
focus to the point that you couldn't be
funny in a way I guess so but that's not
why I never got married
no it's funny as I listen to you you
know as we've repaired our relationship
yes one of the nice things about it is
I've been able to listen you also you're
in the car always now so it's fantastic
a night and you know I really enjoy it
I'm a fan thank you and I'm view and
what I find is that we're alike in so
many ways except that way right you know
you asked me if is it is it the career
that would hurt the marriage no it's not
that it's just that I never understood
how I mean I've tried to have
relationships I've been in love I've
known some amazing couple right but I
never understood how you can be with the
same person just day after day week
after week month after month year after
year I just don't get my god I find it
so I know you did wonderful and relaxed
right and that I don't feel that
pressure right and you know how weird it
is to bring somebody new into your life
I mean yes there's some keys used to it
yeah seriously worried that like
somebody could like you know go to the
press with about something happens and
that you know what I mean I mean yes
first you're not an idiot and you're not
gonna bring in some you know some mania
so if you're a nice person and treat
people well that's what's less of a
concern most people who get in trouble
it's because they do schmucky things and
that's not to say people can't take a
shot at you just because they see you're
an easy target people do that all the
time and I'm aware of that but you can't
live your life worrying about what bad
[ __ ] might happen that's true but you
love being alone you all said you love
it in other words you wake up one
morning you're happy to be by yourself
wrecked and if something funny hits you
you can write it down you can go too I
like all my time to decide what to do
with all my time what's your day today
because I because I like your schedule
in my mind that you you you'll do
stand-up maybe on a weekend right most
comedians I speak to do not love hitting
the road oh no is it possible in your
career now at the point that you're at
because you're well-known on TV you're
famous
can you bomb on a given night no no
can't bomb biggest the people who come
first of all I'm doing this 40 years you
can't you don't bomb but the people who
come to see you are people who paid a
hard money ticket that's the only place
I work I get offered lots of things I
don't want to work corporate gigs why
because I'm not a corporate person I get
these calls and the money is outrageous
right
it's like triple what you'd normally
make in a night I don't care what the
money is that's another great thing
about being this age you cannot buy me
fry time is so much more important than
money to me to get me to do something
you could offer me millions of dollars
to go to Dubai and do a show know
millions of dollars will not change my
life I'm a simple guy right I you know
people say how'd you get enough money to
buy into the Mets you have no overhead I
sit no wives no alimony
yeah no stupid hobbies no no not a no
car kalokhe are collecting their
children no blame no hookers no heroin
no gambling I just like what I like weed
and people give me weed I never have to
buy weed